okay so I've had a very interesting day
on Twitter today been called a few
names I think I need to tell my side of
things and then we can go from there
welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie
Channel so if you don't follow me on
Twitter I'm not going to be on there
very long today went I think I might
have to delete it but uh J mikinski was
asked about the video I did about five
he was asked whether he believed um
these rumors were true about um his
liveaction show and I've basically said
um in my um in my video that um The
Source I've been speaking to has said
that they believe the liveaction reboot
is pretty much dead um that seems to be
the main point of contention that I've
said it's dead rather than life support
or
something um and that um there's very
very unlike ly that it'll ever come back
um by that I mean that it'll it's very
unlikely it'll ever get
kicked jamus was asked about this he
said that's not true um this guy on this
channel says lots of things that are
untrue we'll come back to that in a
second um and
basically um the liveaction reboot is on
hold currently while Warner Brothers is
looking at the merger with Paramount
once that is sorted and set L which will
take a while um but once that is s
settled then Warner Brothers intend
sending the script out to um uh stream
providers now I've been saying for about
a year the Warner Brothers were
interested in selling this to streamers
that it's not going to the CW anymore
and they've been looking for other um
potential buyers so Apple Amazon even
Netflix apparently have expressed an
interest at different times over the
last 12 months or so obviously we've
this we've had the strikes and
everything else which have delayed and
cocked all these plans up JMS actually
said Every Time Warner Brothers are
about to send the scripts
out um something happens the the strikes
bubble
up so let's just break this down for
one from what I'm being told the no I I
I'm I'm not aware that the script for
this pilot that he's already written has
been sent out my understanding from what
JMS has said is that he would be he is
contractor obliged that if he they were
to send a script that he's written out
to anyone they would have to notify him
um or if there's any progression in any
deal they have to notify him I've not
said that's the case I've not said that
the script has gone out I've not said
that this is officially progressed
anywhere I've said there's been
conversations my understanding is that
those are informal conversations it
would be are you interested in this H
probably not at the moment that's as far
as I'm aw where they've gone so by
saying this is dead I should clarify
that cuz maybe I'm being a bit
provocative with the word saying it's
dead maybe uh that is a poor choice of
words I did in the video say that it's
very very unlikely now that this is
going to move forward so that's what my
source has said so it's as good as
dead what I'm being told is Warner
Brothers has has said to a couple of
streaming providers that we're
interested in P pushing forward Pabon 5
and those streaming providers for
different reasons have said we don't
want to go forward that at the moment
now JMS is basically saying the same
thing the reason the difference
basically is that the reasoning for that
is different he believes that there's a
pause because they're waiting for um the
Warner Brothers Paramount deal to go
through a deal that is by no stretch of
the imagination certain there has been
very initial conversations between
Warner Brothers and Paramount but other
parties are interested and are making um
formal movements towards poy trying to
buy those shares so the Warner Brothers
Paramount deal is not definite
yet so I don't know why they'd be
waiting on that but apparently call
jamus they are so that's fine they're
waiting for the dust to settle basically
that's what jamus has said and that that
yeah makes
sense it that's basically what my source
is telling me though that that yes
they're waiting for the dust to settle
and they're waiting for other things but
at the end of the day they don't want it
right
now now I know that's a little bit
pedantics but it's important at the end
of the day as it stands today there are
no plans for the show to move
forwards things can change things can
change but I can't control that you
can't control that JMS can't control
that so when J micinski says that there
are Ser streaming providers that have
expressed an interest in this and say
they are interested in seeing the script
I know that's true because I've been
telling you guys for 12 months that
that's true I know though however at
some point in the last month that has
changed slightly and that they might not
be as interested as they were they might
still be interested to see the script
I'm not saying they're not but what I'm
saying is my source is telling me and
I've got three different sources on this
from different viewpoints so I'm not
just getting this from one person but my
source is telling me that the people
that have expressed an interest in
seeing that script are not so Keen at
the moment because they don't believe
fans actually want a liveaction reboot
and that it would have some negativity
attached to it if they did a live action
reboot
so that is that is all I've said now JMS
on Twitter then did come to me and said
well you said that there is development
work being done on the animated
movie and I actually initially said no I
haven't I've never said that but I
actually did go back to a video I did
last week when I first got this
information and when I watched it again
I realized I did say that I did say that
the animated movie was in serious
development now that's not quite right
I've used the wrong word there
because when work starts on something so
um in this case Warner Brothers are
thinking seriously about doing an
animated movie they want to do more
movies so they are starting and they've
started some work on that but the studio
initially starts to have to think about
okay well this is how well Road home did
this is how well um other Babylon 5 star
done this is how much money we think
it'll cost to make a movie this is how
much money we think we'll make they
basically ask um consultancy firms to do
sort of like studies for them and things
or before they make a decision on
whether they're going to do it or not
that's the work that I'm aware is being
done at the moment that they're looking
at that and I know that because one of
my sources is connected to that area of
of the
industry they do not go and will not
speak to JMS until they've made that
decision they're not going to go to JMS
and go we might do a movie do you you
want to do a script they'll go to him
once they've got their ducks in a row
and they know what they're doing and
then they will ask him to do a script
and they will order a script basically
and move forwards so that's one
thing there's a similar Point here
though when JMS is talking about that no
conversations are happening because
those conversations are clearly
happening because I I and I made the
point on Twitter about this it is a
little bit like when a big sports team
goes for a new signing they quite like
to know what the answer is going to be
before they ask so when they're going
for a new big100 million sign in they
sort of talk to the agent on the choir
they do some things they they try to
find out if the person wants to be
involved this is a similar sort of
process in that it seems that Warner
Brothers are trying to figure out if
other people because they don't want to
make this themselves they want to make
it for somebody else they want to know
that other people are interested before
they make any sort of form formal start
sending out you know scripts and stuff
so that is what I'm aware those are the
conversations I'm aware of them trying
to figure
out what the what what the interest
is JMS would not be informed about that
unless they have to tell him I'm afraid
that I'm afraid that's just the truth
they
wouldn't now jams then accused me of
saying that
um sorry sorry just got back a second so
jamus made that point I said he G to
development I apologize I corrected it
if you a regular sereer and follow my
tweet my feed the Community page you'll
see that I corrected it immediately I
pinned saying I've misspoke there I
didn't mean that I didn't mean it's in
development I mean this on work being
done it's not in development if project
goes into development that is like
scripts being written script being
developed that is a is a different thing
I'm saying that's I've not said that's
happening I well I did say that but I
said it a mistake so I misspoke on a li
on a video that I was doing from the a
front of my real job um in one take um
and I didn't have the opportunity I and
I didn't I didn't watch it back so I
didn't pick up the mistake basically so
I corrected that I apologized um I said
that's not what I meant he then accused
me though saying that I have repeatedly
said that there's been talks between JMS
and Warner Brothers about um the
animated movie and I said no I haven't I
haven't said that I said it once that
was similar th I said it once but I said
they were I had heard I'd been told that
apparently and that's an important word
there apparently so I don't know if it's
I'm not 100% certain whether it's
accurate or not so I you know I use
language that's supposed to express that
but apparently they were about to tap
him up which means they were thinking
about talking to him about a script not
that they have done so I've never said
that I said that to jamus he called me a
bad word and then blocked me and and
then two or three of his um
followers have then gone on a massive
trolling campaign against me on Twitter
and it's become very unpleasant um I've
had to sort of ignore it so um I was
very I think I was very polite they call
me names they call me all sorts of
things to put this in a nutshell
though I don't think jams is being lied
to by anybody I just think they're not
telling him certain bits of information
that he doesn't need to know I don't
think jmss is lying to us because he's
not that sort of person I have only ever
said that I think JMS is a freaking
genius and that I love his work and that
I would love babyon 5 to
return but I'm being told different
things from sources I trust so I'm going
to share that with you guys I hope those
sources are wrong I hope a streaming
provider does step forward and want to
buy this show because I'd love to see
what JMS is going to do with it I'm more
thany happy to be wrong but at the
moment sadly I don't think I am jmss has
got a little bit annoyed with
me partly because I don't think he's
maybe watched all the videos and
actually listened to everything I've
said so maybe he's taken U me out of
context a little bit also because
Babylon 5 is very close to me he doesn't
like what I'm saying um and maybe his
agent and things are saying other things
but you know okay um so I don't blame
jams for getting annoyed at me I don't
like that he call me a bad word and I
don't like they call me a liar but you
know what can you do about that as far
as he's concerned I am so he just thinks
I'm another one of those idiot YouTubers
that just say whatever to get
clicks his acolytes or the people that
think they're defending him to be
honest they've not watched my videos
they don't know what I said in the first
place and they've all blissfully ignored
the fact that I have repeatedly said I
did not say that JMS was in talks with
anybody about the animated movie and
I've not said that they completely just
ignore me when I keep saying that so
they just say that's that's what that is
so anyway I'm going to go away and make
a decision about whether I want to stay
on Twitter or not leaning towards not oh
my God it's it was proper school boy
bully tactics is ridiculous some of the
things these people were saying ah um
and as far as JMS goes look if he finds
out that what I've said is actually
accurate I'm hoping he comes back to me
and and you know and just sort of says
yeah you were
right um if his agent whatever tells him
that if they don't in a couple of years
if we don't get babyon 5 you know always
right so but at the end of the
day yeah I I can't tell you who my
sources are so I can't prove that I'm
right so if you don't believe me to be
honest I don't blame you you've got to
take everything that people say on
YouTube with a pinch of salt all I can
do is try to be as honest with you guys
as I can
be and we'll see how it goes but guys
get into the comments tell me what you
think um and if you're new to the
channel like subscribe all that business
it's not one of the videos that really
want to say that particularly not that
sort of video but anyway thanks for
watching I'll see you next time maybe
not on Twitter
[Music]
though